ahora que sabemos cómo multiplicar
números con signos distintos vamos a
tratar de explorar qué pasa cuando los
dividimos y vamos a descubrir que
realmente es un procedimiento muy
similar si los dos números tienen el
mismo signo nos va a dar un positivo por
ejemplo un positivo entre un positivo
nos da un positivo y un negativo entre
un negativo nos da un positivo también
pero si uno de ellos tiene el signo
contrario al otro por ejemplo un
positivo entre un negativo o un negativo
entre un positivo entonces el resultado
será negativo vamos a hacer algunos
ejemplos ok 8 entre -2 y simplemente
tuviera 8 entre 2 si me olvido el signo
el resultado sería 4
pero como tengo un positivo dividido
entre un negativo el resultado es
negativo así que el resultado de esta
primera ecuación es menos 4 muy bien
ahora sí divido menos 16 entre 4
entonces que obtengo 16 entre 4
es simplemente 4 positivo pero de nuevo
tengo un signo negativo aquí y sólo 1
así que esto es un negativo entre un
positivo y eso es un número negativo
tengo que tener que exactamente uno de
ellos sea negativo y el otro positivo en
ese caso sí exactamente uno es negativo
y el otro es positivo me da un número
negativo muy bien ahora menos 30 entre
menos 5 30 entre 5 y 6
y como tengo un negativo entre un
negativo los negativos se cancelan y el
resultado es positivo podría si quisiera
escribir un pequeño + aquí aunque
realmente no es necesario ok
18 entre 2 esta pregunta es algo
truculenta está aquí metida pero
realmente son dos números positivos así
que esto ya lo sabemos hacer desde hace
muchísimo tiempo y 18 entre 2 nosotros
ya sabemos que nos da 9 positivo es un
positivo entre un positivo muy bien
ahora menos 7 por 3 entre menos uno y
sólo hago una observación rápida este
punto de aquí este punto significa
multiplicación se usa porque en álgebra
el signo por muchas veces se puede
confundir con la equis y la equis es
esencial en el álgebra así que muchas
veces verán este punto pero bueno vamos
a hacer menos 7 por 3 y el resultado
dividirlo entre menos 17 por 3 sería 21
21 pero tengo un negativo por un
positivo así que este resultado también
debe ser negativo así que tengo menos 21
dividido entre menos 121 entre 1 es 21
- entre menos nos da más así que solo
tengo 21 positivo de hecho vamos a notar
estas reglas si tengo un positivo
y lo divido entre otro positivo
obtengo un número positivo
si tengo un positivo y lo divido entre
un negativo
obtengo un negativo
si tengo un negativo
y lo divido entre un negativo
obtengo un positivo los dos tienen el
mismo signo así que se cancela
finalmente si tengo un negativo y lo
divido entre un positivo entonces el
resultado es negativo signos contrarios
me dan números negativos signos iguales
me dan números positivos ok ahora para
hacer este último problema vamos a
podemos hacerlo en cualquier orden vamos
a hacer primero menos 2 x menos 7 y el
resultado por menos 1 así que menos 2 x
menos 7 sería 14
14 porque 2 por 7 es 14 menos por menos
me da más así que este es un número
positivo 14 positivo por menos 114 por
menos 1 el resultado de eso es 14 por 1
es 14 pero más por menos aquí podría
poner un pequeño más más por menos
me da menos así que el resultado es
menos 14
y de hecho podríamos explorar algunas
preguntas un poco capciosas por ejemplo
cuánto es 0 entre menos 5 pues en este
caso el resultado es 0 no importa el
signo de el menos de aquí abajo
el resultado será 0 y que hay por
ejemplo de 5 entre 0 pues está la
división entre 0 no está definida así
que esto comúnmente se diría que está
indefinido indefinido
y también por ejemplo qué pasaría con 0
entre 0 un número entre otros números
generalmente da 1 pero si tenemos una
división entre 0 entonces de nuevo
decimos que esto está indefinido y bueno
espero que estos ejemplos les hayan
aclarado un poco la situación